students teachers government employees
and social media Executives all Under
One Roof their goal to combat the
scourge of fake news a campaign
Philippine president Ferdinand Marcus Jr
launched in August what we are fighting
for is the truth because the very first
casualty of all of these is the truth
this forum officials say will be
followed by a road show to schools
Filipinos are especially vulnerable to
disinformation because of the amount of
time they spend on social media nearly
90% of 16 to 64 year olds are in
Facebook and according to the 2021
borders Institute digital news report
nine out of 10 Filipinos are exposed to
fake news but it certainly isn't a
problem that's unique to this country
some have had disastrous consequences
like the allegations of vote rigging in
the 2020 presidential election in the
United States that led to the attack on
the capital and during war such as the
one Israel is waging on Gaza now this
information can spread even faster and
so what the breaking news shelf does is
to actually show you content from
vetted uh authoritative news outlets
such that when you search Gaza Hospital
explosion you're not bombarded with
disinformation analysis of the bombing
of Al Ali Baptist Hospital in Gaza on
October the 17th are inconclusive but in
the case of the 2022 election
researchers say there's ample evidence
that this information helped Propel
Marcus to the presidency something that
casts a shadow on his effort to address
the problem they're trying to build a
monument for the president's father for
his supposed contribution and the g War
we've pointed out already that it has no
basis in history in fact critics say the
government may be on the right track but
the real test is whether it can and will
fact check whitewashed narratives of the
Marcus family's role during a dark
period in the Philippines history Barner
below aljazera
Manila make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer